توافد ليبيون الثلاثاء للادلاء باصواتهم
في انتخابات المؤتمر الوطني العام في اولى
مراكز الاقتراع الست في العالم في مدينه
دبي بدوله الامارات العربيه المتحده ومن
المقرر ان يضع المؤتمر الوطني العام
الدستور الوطني ومن ثم تشكيل الحكومه
الليبيه القادمه وحرصت المفوضيه الوطنيه
العليا للانتخابات على توفير السبل لتسهيل
عمليه التصويت للناخبين في مقر القنصليه
الليبيه بدبي طبعا
الدوائر تقسمت الى 73 دائره دائره فرعيه
في منها حصوت بطريقه القائمه وفي منها
حصوت بطريقه الافراد وفي اللي ح يصوت
بطريقه الافراد والقائمه مع طبعا الناس ح
تصوت كل حسب حسب دائرته كل شيء واضح وعننا
ثقه في كل الناس الشغالين معاي
معنا كلهم يعني الليبيين
و الحمد
لله وعمت اجواء الفرح بين الناخبين في خوض
تجربه الانتخابات التي حرم منها الشعب
الليبي لعده عقود طبعا شعور غير
عادي لحظه تاريخيه
جدا واححد تنتابه يعني شعور ما عمرش يعني
لاول مره في عمره عمري 44 سنه لاول مره في
حياتي
ان نخوض التجربه هذه اللي هي تجربه
الانتخابات الشعب الليبي المترب شعر
بالتميز الانتخابات من اماره دبي كان لنا
بالذات احنا في الامارات شرف ان نفتتح هذا
العهد بحكم فارق التوقيت وكذا فكانت دبي
هي الاولى فهذا شرف يعني هنفخ به في
التاريخ واتمنى البعض ان تكون الانتخابات
بدايه مبشره للخير يضمن مستقبل الاجيال
القادمه نحن يعمنا الخير وحنمشي الامور
الى الامام وحن ان شاء الله انتخبوا ناس
هم الوطنيين هم اللي يحبوا ليبيا هم اللي
يشيلو البر الامان ان شاء الله باسرع وقت
باذن الله ويبقى الامل في ان تحقق تجربه
الانتخابات الاولى في تاريخ ليبيا الامن
والاستقرار الحقيقيين على الارض عبد
الرحمن بحيك سي ان ان بالعربيه
دبي